yeah welcome to this video the video um
which is also for testing the audio I
got a new microphone and I hope this
resolves some issues with background
noise that I that has suffered from so
we've got a modern defense with d6 g6
Bishop g7 okay and um it can transpose
to irregular Kings Indian but it seems
that black isn't ending to first make a
couple of other moves okay so let's go
d5 at least he cannot do night f6 now
and also not 97 because I simply take on
on c6 so on maybe black needs to play c5
now or something like this okay hmm
yeah how to continue I play Bishop to g5
I can also play a Bishop b3 or or
something but my ideas to provoke the h6
move I think this is helpful to have
been because of the pawns are somewhat
vulnerable here to g4 and h4 and so on
so on let's play g4 h4 h5 this typical
space gaining maneuver I can also I
could also have played just castles and
play on the Queen side but I'd like to
first gain space here on nor the King
side this kind of position type where
black and has played very passively in
the center it's some very well known to
be a very problematic for black to be a
to be friendly about that I think some
people yeah and now after you fire from
this position is some almost winning for
white in a strategical sense you get
this rather often the only issue is that
it is very closed and needs uh some
patients to convert but White has huge
some space advantage yeah this is what
they often do try to close up everything
but why this got a three before and also
yeah this is a cool also White has got
this f5 square as the possible post for
for night yeah I'm not not so sure what
he's doing maybe he's even repairing
b-52 to open it up himself
which is close to suicidal the only
chance is to keep the position as close
as possible
so the kingside is completely completely
locked up so there's never going to
heaven any opening of the position the
only way black can do something he has
to sacrifice on g4 or similar but this
is very difficult to achieve it's it's
almost never possible I'm in the form of
a correct sacrifice you can only yeah
you can only sacrifice um incorrectly
and hope that you sort of get away with
it okay so I'm doubling on the beef out
this is the farm I'm going to open yeah
just make sure for that he is not able
to play a five at some point yeah the
way to continue would be rook a2 b1
doubling and then and then there's some
more than one possibility you can try a
four a five but you must must make sure
that on a for the moose a5 as a response
as some it's actually okay for white so
that just so can open the position it
might happen that the position is so
close that you cannot win a question is
if the knight on on g3 is so great
actually it it always some keeps an eye
on the f5 Square to help against
possible breaks but maybe it is an idea
to reroute the knight to 1 to D 2 and
cavalry form so this kind of way
night on D 2 and then prepare the
maneuver Bishop d3 2 C 2 2 a for M get
rid of the the bad bishop and exchange
this against the g7 bishop this would be
a way to to make progress trying to do
that I couldn't do this before because
he for was hanging he had maybe the
possibility to take on c4 at some point
yeah black is basically a mostly
shuffling around one idea for him could
be to take and play b5 make sure make
use of this this night on on c3 okay
still if he takes I can also take with
the rook this shouldn't be shouldn't be
bad at all opening the position in some
way must be helpful okay
he's obviously not listening to that
comments it's a hit sometimes really
funny that you say okay I cannot do that
and just as I say say it he's playing
exactly the smooth but I think I can
just take B 5 I don't really see why I
shouldn't take it yes he can we have
this is the only the only hope to to
move the pawn I want to have the knight
on f5 quickly he does I don't care so
much about the a pawn must be this this
year rugby 795 must be really strong I
mean what what is he doing now for
defense he still has got terrible pieces
9f5 is also with check but is this is it
winning yeah that looks terrible but
yeah yeah if he doesn't if he goes to
age seven he is still in the pin and if
he goes somewhere else I can also take
just h6 oh yeah how to win now there
must be a win I mean cannot believe this
isn't that this shouldn't be a shouldn't
be winning d6 yeah it's it's very
dominating but how how to win actually
just bishop somewhere Bishop to b6 yeah
you need to play queen - two - yeah here
and then maybe there's some some way to
adjust six of course yeah it took me
really no - good to see that it's not
easy or not difficult
so it's just just a piece right bishop
to a form idea it's nothing really
threatening yeah I've got it
got the deep bone as well yeah this is a
really a typical kind of position which
you you rather often get in deep wound
openings against Kings Indian type
setups the the point is is simply that
this structure is very very bad
kind of curious but what the computer
assesses this you know one pawn for
white yeah this is maybe a bad ride yeah
but black should do try to do is to
avoid this this kind of structure one
idea is actually in this position to
maybe go Knight to g5 this is so this
may be an idea to have a good night
position here maybe this is a
problematic due to some concrete play
like taking an aged six but this is
simply a problem yeah also a very
important thing if black plays the for
instance plays c5 here then it would be
a mistake for white to do this
this is actually a pretty good position
for black I wanna pawn but I don't have
any concrete play on the edge file he's
got this line and square on a form I
mean okay this is probably not an
advantage for black but because the
queenside is closed if black would have
some dynamic play on the queenside then
this would be really really good for him
this is probably just just okay for
black not not an advantage white can
castle long quickly and play Knight f1
III and so on but the general idea is
that this porn lost on h6 isn't so so
problematic yeah thanks for watching
this and make sure to write some some
feedback about the audio I hope it is
fine now thanks